okay so kim kardashian posted a photo of
a painting on her ig story
and she said that uh her daughter north
was a bunch uh i was she like nine
ten is she no no i don't think she's
seven right northwest is your name right
yeah yeah northwest i know because
people think it's fake right
yeah so she's seven and uh kim said that
she was taking a bunch of painting
lessons and that
she was proud of the work that north did
so she posted a photo of it onto her
instagram story
and a bunch of people were making fun of
her saying north absolutely didn't paint
this why are you
trying to do all this for the gram and
she went off on a bunch of people but
people are also kind of right
i don't think you don't think sh
paint that paint the hair she got
five-year-old man you've been painting
for a minute
or drawn from this and then she also
followed this with
a post of art that kanye did when he was
a kid that showed his
like artistic he was big and high when
he was young right yeah some people get
it
maybe do you think they ain't spending
the money for her to get the best
uh painting trainer to help her out
she's seven
artists artists there you go thanks dog
maybe this is the artwork that she said
kanye did when he was a kid i don't know
how old he was and what like kid
kind of was 27 years old
[Laughter]
he did that last week so here's some of
kanye's stuff when he's 37
to back off you know i'm telling you man
you know
i'm around five year olds i and i see
all their their their paintings and
drawings and stuff
maybe they're two years older maybe they
got savon on their hands but
it ain't even close
i think it could happen it could happen
let me see youtube's seven-year-old
painting this kid's 11. he's 11.
but that's pretty good damn 11 to 7 is a
huge huge disadvantage it is a huge
difference five to seven's insane
difference maybe
you know i like to think that she's not
[ __ ] but also the kardashians so
everything's smoke and mares right
from their looks everything they're
doing so it's like
it's hard to believe anything that's
more like it i think right you know what
right here like that kind of painting
art yeah like it was like
a shirt like my son will bring home and
i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
alligators don't have wings
like you know it's not going to make the
fridge homeboy you know it's like i
can't put no alligator with wings on my
[ __ ] fridge
it's a dragon dog goddamn well
[ __ ] gorillas don't have scales
the [ __ ] they bring homie like dude why
did your teacher tell you
yeah he'll bring just some wild [ __ ] oh
my god and one eye's like bigger than
the other
it's gonna steer your little brother
bruh
so you're saying no uh i'd be
it's like it's a kardashian i'm gonna
believe it you don't believe it yeah i
like to believe it
i mean her dad is kanye west who when he
you know kind of savant when it comes to
music
that's bob ross that is tough to do man
yeah that is [ __ ] tough to do
as seven now did the teacher probably
help a lot yeah
yeah maybe she did the grass yeah maybe
she did the grass but the water yeah
she is but the the problem is again the
connection
she even signed it yeah sure but one eye
is bigger than the other in her
all right even this like just a
reflection here and then it's blue
that tree bro yeah go to their mouth
everything no that's that's amazing work
and god pop more power to her if she's
really painting those i don't believe it
but what i know i'm just around kids all
the time and there's some little there's
some talented kids at tiger's school
and they ain't doing that [ __ ] same
stuff right
damn i guess i'm the only one that
believes you don't believe in alec
it's fun to believe but also it's the
kardashians like her face and ass are
fake i'm supposed to expect this
painting's real
you know what i'm saying they're going
through a divorce and [ __ ] acting like
everything's their fair point
come on ain't nothing real about the
kardashians and i'm a fan
i'm a fan of i think it's real so
speaking of free brittany there was an
old uh video footage from craig ferguson
where he refused to mock
uh britney spears on his show way back
in the day and it's going viral now
now i remember what's happened it's been
happening in the press in the media
recently and particularly in the
so-called news outlets
looking at the world i i kind
when i used to watch america's funniest
home videos you know you'd be laughing
at the kid falling over and then you go
wait a minute put down the damn camera
and help your kids
what's wrong with you and i and i
and i think we're kind of holding the
cam and people are falling apart
right people are people are dying that
anna nicole smith woman she
died not it's not a joke
you know it's it stops being funny that
she's got a six week old kid or six
month old kid
what the hell is that you know and i i
i'm starting to feel uncomfortable
about making fun of these people and for
me combination of a certain amount of
joy in it it should be about
about us attacking the powerful people
attacking the politicians and the
and the trumps and the and the blue
hearts of the world
going after them we should be attacking
the vulnerable people
and i think i i'm gonna this is totally
a miracle this is just for me
i think my aim's been off a bit recently
i i want to change a bit so tonight
no britney spears jokes this woman has
two kids
she's 25 years old she's a baby herself
she's a baby that's great damn that was
probably
up to him man yeah shout out to craig
for that one yeah
yeah yeah only the other media members
were like that
yeah it's just like i mean like
when you make jokes on her it's just
kind of low-hanging fruit yeah it's
weird
it's kind of just kind of weak
especially during that time it was just
like bro
everyone's just [ __ ] with her i mean
what you said a million dollars for a
picture for the million dollars for a
picture
why britney spears she get no money she
don't get none of that money
yeah can you go take a picture of me and
make a million off of it i don't see
none of it
and that's why you start and only fancy
exactly
all right i'll get this black
ding-a-ling out
and black
[Laughter]
a lot of money
big bbm [ __ ] okay jason
couldn't stop laughing there was a
lawyer who was on a zoom call with a
judge and another lawyer
uh and they were supposed to discuss the
case but for some reason one of the
lawyers he couldn't get this cat filter
off of his zoo
i'm here live i'm not a cat
let me see this chip
[Laughter]
uh
oh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's not i'm not a cat
no [ __ ] it's me fellas it's not a cat
no [ __ ] for the sound of this arrow next
to this
i love
i love like you try to explain the cat
eyes just get sad
i'm live
speaking of kids vernon you are a fan
said this in right
uh jay sent this to me jason that's okay
um it's kids
scarface is a kid's school place yeah
i've seen this insane you've never seen
no is it funny i don't think it was real
i thought that was like a joke old video
no it's an old video
this is dope say hello hold on
can't you stop things like all the time
it's
boring tony what what's boring
you're boring
[Music]
come on michelle pfeiffer yeah you do
coke and you
kill people that's wonderful honey
i got a [ __ ] drink for a while
you son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm leaving you [ __ ]
man
there's an audience for this
[Laughter]
security cameras parents helped out with
this [ __ ] too
okay so sir you want to fudge me you're
fine you're the best
well say hello to my little friends
oh my god what school approved this
i don't know that's cool the world is
yours
what the [ __ ]
but also awesome this is funny how i
said the world is yours
[Laughter]
that's unbelievable so hard for me to
believe it's real
unreal i'm wonderful yeah all right so
this thing is going viral
it's kind of frustrating when i watch it
but i'll just play it for you so people
are on her side by the way
the which on whose side this girl who
just came back from hot yoga
and she's talking about what fitness
instructors what they say how it's not
cool
so i'll play it for now let's ignore the
fact that my teeth are purple
[Music]
the most annoying thing i think about
going to
a workout class i went to a socially
distanced
hot yoga class love hot yoga but i hate
when the instructors
go off and say we're gonna you know work
off all those cheat meals
i and they just keep talking about the
food you may have eaten and how exercise
is just to combat the food that you eat
food is fuel it's not something you need
to
fear you need to work off like they go
hand in hand
they're not like fighting each other
like they work together
you need to eat anyways that's it that's
my rant
um
[Music]
yeah so here's the thing that's just
like and she's getting all the support
too it's like
that's what's wrong with that girl take
ownership of your fat body it's like no
hold on
her cholesterol is through the roof now
you're [ __ ]
i'm glad she has a super positive
attitude about life
you're out of shape girl and so you go
that class and they're trying to tell
you hey
you're trying to burn off these cars
because you ate like [ __ ] yeah
those are facts but that's it's easy to
go yeah i'm fat and i eat this
and you know i'm sick of them telling me
i need to stop being like this because
that's that's the easy route
it's not cool to drink it does not make
your body feel good
no i don't feel good depending on what
you eat depending on what you eat
it's also depending on what you eat
right so if you good stuff but not that
much here's the thing
start your own class girls you seem like
you can be a great instructor especially
with that mindset
no you win it i'm sick of it what world
are we no you're not
yeah no you didn't though no you
wouldn't no you would cause you're
listen
more power to you you're severely out of
shape
you don't know how to work out you don't
know how to eat right you don't have any
discipline
it's yeah it's like it's just saying
that it's just saying like they're
like they're mean for saying like we're
working on food no that's what we're
doing i'm just telling you like hey
it's not me then everyone who rallies
around her is also
on discipline and out of shape yeah but
it's so much easier to go
yeah don't let them shame me for eating
like that girl no no [ __ ] no
the problem you can eat like that but
you like that every day every day
and that is that's not cool are those
all those uh balls there's a lot of
sugar full of sugar delicious
full of sugar i mean yeah of course
they're delicious that's why
but there's a lot of sugar in there well
it's a brazilian uh
cuisine i mean appetite just because
it's brazilian well american we could
put more sugar in it but
got it guys but again it's they say it's
healthy for you in brazil
but over here it's too much sugar sugar
sugar it's a lot of calories
yeah yep a ton of sugar no matter what
like my boy
henry grace eats it every day but he
doesn't need any carbs you need bread
now also like yeah he's watching them
yeah so i mean they kind of have to tell
you
you know they have to guide you on what
to [ __ ] eat and what not to [ __ ]
eat right
let's just assume that this instructor
is skinny
okay so earlier y'all was talking about
skinny people
telling people
hey you went on this whole wreck yeah if
you don't come from this
maybe that instructor is thick and got
in shape i bet you that instructor has
discipline though huh i wish you that
instructor
i mean yeah we didn't sound like that
you don't know we didn't really sound
like that girl
no no no i hate women no we didn't no we
didn't
because if that instructor was thick and
lost
weight i'm going to listen to that
person oh yeah we don't know what the
destruction is no i have no clue
that's what i'm saying i see what you're
just saying nothing's true
like rail [ __ ] who's like don't eat
that acai you work it off girl it's like
what the [ __ ] you talking about yeah
yeah work it out what have you worked on
yeah
i appreciate you calling society's weird
though where they rally around that
because that every
because it's so much harder to lose
weight and be disciplined
but what are they saying like one of the
big things of like kovid
is like if you're if you're overweight
out of shape and if it gets you she's
gonna get you
like if she got cold but she's fine you
know what i'm saying so like so like are
we shaming or is it
yeah it's just weird that like no i get
what he's saying so
start your own class no relax no yeah
yeah yeah i don't know but
again i don't think if i if i walked in
a hot yoga
and that was the instructor i'd walk
right out
yoga yogurt's supposed to make you sweat
you know you're supposed to be skinny
i just think there's nothing wrong with
saying burning off food that's all i
don't think yeah yeah
yeah what she's what she's upset about i
don't think
any nice instructors like hey you
probably have that cheap meal today
that's going to help you burn this off
you know
yeah that's right promoting health yeah
and what you say like
food is fuel but like also what the [ __ ]
food is fuel yeah no we get that for
survival we get that we've gone way past
that girl
i'm eating your ass first if this plane
crashed
[Laughter]
um justin bieber i got he got this
custom rolls royce from
that one place you know west coast
customs pin my right place
and i don't know what i think about it
it looks cool in a picture but then
here's a yeah yeah let's go it's
customers just go to
too much yeah i mean the front looks
cool back or some [ __ ]
i also pick my ride people yeah yeah oh
[ __ ]
back looks cool like you we know you
like roller skates so we put a roller
rink in the back
and a trunk where they put everything in
people's cars i think it'd be dope if
they didn't do those
fenders on the wall yeah unless it was
floating or something but there's going
to be wheels under it it looks kind of
cheesy i think
got it yeah yeah but that's it justin
bieber just got that
yeah he sent it there for them to hook
it up
yeah [ __ ] yeah these guys they just with
their imagination you got to tell them
what to do
if you drop it off and like go crazy
they just go overboard yeah
i mean that at least it's cleaner but i
just don't like the console because it's
hiding the wheels the wheels yeah
because
you know the wheels are under there yeah
like a wide body would be sick
yeah um so these paranaques designed for
barack obama have gone for 25k
44th president on them those are sick i
would not
i would rock the [ __ ] you rocked the
[ __ ] out oh i don't think i can
is there only one pair yeah yeah that's
why there's only one pair that's why i'm
25 grand
yeah those are [ __ ] sick man
i can't tell those are saucy would you
rock those man
i'll play all of them those are sick
hyperdumps are dope
yeah yeah bruno mars and someone else
performed
was it that adam levine yeah was it adam
moving oh maroon five room four five
yeah yeah yeah i was like sorry i
thought the weekends was the best as far
as like performances
his was [ __ ] really when they really
sing i'm into it when it's lip singing i
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah temple looked lit yeah yeah
somebody white after parties white mike
kept uh texting me man
florida don't give a [ __ ] florida won't
give a [ __ ] that's what he kept texting
me the whole [ __ ] time
damn they don't no they don't hopefully
they carry that same energy when i'm
there in two weeks
tampa yeah temple florida yeah totally
keep that same energy yeah i know
damn how about that when i get off stage
with the laugh actually
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song